This story is almost beyond belief, except
if you've been paying attention to the last
four years, you won't be that surprised by
it.
As you might know, Donald Trump and Trump
cultists are increasingly mad at Fox News
because anecdotally, some Fox News anchors
have acknowledged and recognized that Joe
Biden won the election.
Trump has increasingly, as a result, been
pushing people to instead watch on and Newsmax,
which are even crazier channels than Fox News.
Ohayon reported a completely laughable conspiracy
theory alleging that because one stream of
Joe Biden's Thanksgiving address had only
a thousand live concurrent viewers, clearly
80 million people couldn't possibly have voted
for Joe Biden in the election a month ago.
Now, you might hear that reasoning and you
might say that that's spurious.
How do these things even relate?
And that would be the correct reaction.
But one person who found it at least credible
enough to tweet was Donald Trump himself,
who tweeted, quote, report, Biden's Thanksgiving
Day address gets just over a thousand views
online, which is not even true, by the way,
a record low, observers say.
And what he means is a guy on Twitter.
Observers say a candidate with 80 million
votes would get many more online viewers.
Numbers don't lie or add up.
Oh, and so here is the report from on that
the president is referring to.
Check out this absurd I mean, to even call
it a report.
I'm really stretching the definition of a
report, but take a look at it.
Well, Joe Biden stirs a new controversy after
his Thanksgiving address fails to attract
viewers.
Reports Thursday found Biden's livestream
address got only one thousand views online.
The former vice president delivered a teleprompter
address on Wednesday and another baseless
attempt to pose as the winner of the recent
elections.
The mainstream media portrays Biden as the
most popular candidate in history of U.S.
politics, giving him 80 million votes.
However, observers say Biden's miserable viewership
online does not reflect his purported popularity.
That is the channel that Trump is now promoting
over Fox News.
This entire thing is just horrifying in terms
of what it means for the country.
Now, I could sit here and fact check, right.
Like I could say, well, listen, it was a thousand
live concurrence, not a thousand views.
And that was on one stream on Twitter.
And if you look at different networks and
YouTube streams and TV, there were actually
millions of live viewers, but that would be
a waste of time.
The people who have decided that Joe Biden
stole the election don't care.
The point is they will seek out anyone who
will keep telling them what they want.
To hear that during some hours of the day
is no longer Fox News, which acknowledges
Biden won.
So during the day when Fox has people who
say, well, the president did lose, they'd
go to Newsmax, they go to on and on, is quite
literally quoting some guy on Twitter about
this so-called theory.
The real story here is how this goes back
to what we talked about earlier this week,
which is that Fox News and Trump, within his
fake news meme, have so radicalized the right
that they just reject anything that is reality
based media.
If it's not what they want to believe and
they look elsewhere, the followers are now
too radical for Fox News.
If you can imagine something so scary and
the truth doesn't matter, you can look around.
Like I said, the NBC stream of the Joe Biden
Thanksgiving address had half a million views.
The Joe Biden YouTube channel stream had 100000
ABC, one hundred and twenty five thousand,
CBS 100000.
The TV networks that covered it, it's not
about that.
Why are we even still talking about Biden's
low ratings as Trump like to talk about them
during the campaign?
The entire framework is online.
Popularity should help us figure out who should
be President Trump's rally sites.
His Twitter followers are indicative of Trump
being a better choice for president.
The fact that people believe that paradigm
is part of the problem and that's unlikely
to change anytime soon.
It's really the appeal to popularity.
You know, sometimes I get emails or messages
from people saying, David, your channel is
terrible and you're lying and you are losing
viewers.
And the truth is the channel has grown every
month for the last decade.
We were the top left wing independent YouTube
channel for live streams of the RNC.
DNC debates, Election Day.
We're close to one point two million subscribers,
more than we've ever had.
We've added 92000 subscribers in the last
four weeks.
But even arguing with them is almost like
participating in the appeal to popularity.
We might have those numbers and be a terrible
channel or not.
Just because something generates eyeballs
doesn't mean it's necessarily good.
And that's very much the case here.
Even if their assertions about Joe Biden's,
you know, views on a Thanksgiving Day address,
it tells us nothing about who won the election
and it tells us nothing about who's the better
choice for president.
But until there's a paradigm shift and these
things are rethought, we're not going to get
out of this sort of death spiral of incompetence.
And it's going to take more than just replacing
Trump with Biden to solve that problem.
It's a much bigger issue.